Jon Favreau's reimagining of the jungle
book has been a huge success and has
pulled the punters in like bears too
honey however this is not the only
adaptation of the classic story that is
to be released in the next couple of
years I'm Simon and this is your
entertainment news update Warner
Brothers are also making a version of
the jungle book but are pushed back the
release date the studio is now looking
at other ways to set it apart from its
smash-hit rival it has now been reported
that gravity and harry potter and the
prisoner of azkaban director alfonso
quran is coming on board to lend a hand
according to Deadline the oscar-winning
filmmaker is joining the project to give
notes and to see how the film can be
improved the site reports that the
studio is sensitive to the suggestion
that Curran is taking over the project
from director Andy Serkis and stresses
that he is purely there as a friend to
the studio production on the film has
already wrapped but earlier this month
Warner made the decision to move the
film back an entire year from its
initial release date on October 2017 to
October 2018 the film originally had the
title jungle book origins but is now
simply called Jungle Book circus took to
Facebook to comment on the decision to
shift the release date stating that he
was absolutely thrilled to have another
year to work on the movie the ambition
for this project is huge he said what we
are attempting is an unprecedented level
of psychological and emotional nuance in
morphing the phenomenal performances of
our cast into the facial expressions of
our animals so every minute more that we
have to evolve the technological
pipeline will make all the difference
the evidence is there already and it's
off the chain exciting so hang on in
there this is truly next-generation
storytelling jungle book has a course
that includes Christian Bale Benedict
Cumberbatch Cate Blanchett and Naomie
Harris it is currently set to be
released on October 19 2018 do you think
it's ironic that the king of mocap has
been trumped by Disney CGI animals or do
you think that circus is destined to do
a great job let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter i'm at
the Jagan all thanks for watching and
for all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot
you